[Music]
hey I'm excited about this I recently
sat down for an interview with my good
friend Dr Caroline
Leaf um she is brilliant brilliant
brilliant beyond all brilliant and she's
done some extraordinary research if
you're not following DR leaf you should
on the on the insta Tik toks on the what
do you call them the snap grams social
media social media yes you should follow
her on that um and pick up her books as
well but we had a long long conversation
together and so we'll release it over
the coming year but this particular
segment was
important I asked her for some
explanation and some some strategies for
teaching kids
self-regulation something that's
increasingly important to me because I
got two kids in my house but also I'm
continually talking to parents about
working with their kids is how do we
teach kids what they're feeling and then
what to do
next because we have a whole generation
just look in Congress we have a whole
generation of adults who don't know how
to do this how do we stop that Madness
and teach this to kids here's what I'm
feeling here's what your body's doing
and then here's what to do next so here
is a segment from my conversation with
the great Dr Caroline leaf on teaching
kids self-regulation check it
out the most common question I
get barnun which is what about my
kids um kids are told by teachers you
have a this kids are sent out of their
classroom because they're a
seven-year-old little boy that we're
told you need to sit in that chair and
sit still for eight hours doing these
worksheets and when they can't we tell
them they're dysfunctional or we have
these young girls who just you know cuz
ADH D is expressed differently in young
women and and and they check out and we
Pat them on the back and say way to go
you sat quietly through class right we
take these kids and we stick them in
these very artificial environments and
then if they roll outside of the bell
curve we blame them for them and then we
have well-meaning heartbroken parents
saying what do I do now right or we have
I would say moderately informed parents
that say this doesn't feel right I know
in my gut this isn't right
um but I don't know what to do and so
I've begun saying hey you got to take
some of this education into your own
hands and then I pick up your book and
it's got sections I'd love to talk about
teaching kids
self-regulation I because that I mean
then you're teaching a kid What a
Feeling is and what an emotion is and
you're teaching them that mindful gap
between stimulus and response if you if
we could teach kids that you're talking
like a global life a world that is a
different world right tot totally
doesn't have politicians popping off at
the you know how it gets we can get
sideways on that but let's talk about
how a single mom with two kids how a
truck driver who just wants to be a
better a more present father how do they
teach their kids
self-regulation well I'm yeah I love how
you framed that question and that whole
background that you gave there because
the one of the main reasons I wrote this
book was because we need to be able to
help parents to be able to do this the
single most important way of helping our
children do this or helping a parent to
help our children is for a parent to
know how to regulate themsel so it
begins with if if we have to start
addressing the Mental Health crisis in
both adults and children but let's talk
about children first is we have to be
able to help a parent help themselves
because the stress of the parent will go
through to the child oh say that again
say that again cuz uh we're going to
preach for a second say that one more
time the the anxiety or stress that a
parent feels is picked up directly by
the child it goes
the child so priority number one and
biggest mental health support is to
educate parents in helping them to say
messy parenting is so normal you don't
have to Cate your life like we see on
the influencer sort of world that we
live in now we have to recognize that
we've got our own baggage we've been
parented by parents that have their
baggage we have the right to honor our
own Trauma from our own parenting that
may have been good and bad everyone
comes to you every parent no matter how
well intentional you're going to mess
your kids up in some way you messed up
in some way that is just the reality and
for some it's obviously way worse than
others you know in extreme situations
but we needed you know there's certain
things that we've got to deal with that
we haven't and it comes true to our kids
so that's a reality and we're going to
make those mistakes so if we can accept
that upfront and give ourselves
compassion and kindness and realize all
right that's I have to honor my story
I'm not not that I'm dishonoring my
parents because they're someone else's
daughter and son you know so therefore
you know it's um they someone else's
daughter or son whatever so therefore we
have to look at two things we have to
honor our story of the impact of our
parenting on us as parents and that does
an recognize that we need to honor our
parent stories and that a lot of what we
experienced it has affected us they also
had to deal with does that make sense
we've got absolutely so it doesn't mean
that if you say okay this is this was
this has come through from my own
nurturing you're not just honoring your
parent you are honoring them because
they also went through their stuff but
you also have the right to work on your
stuff so that's very important because
parent guilt is a massive massive issue
and the thing that you've got to be
perfect parents is absolute nonsense
because parenting is not going to be
perfect all the time as we all know okay
so that means that I need to be able to
know how to deal with my own stuff so
when I'm reactive to my kids for example
um you as a truck driver that example
you gave or just wanting to be a good
parent and help their child or Mom Mom
Dad family big family life things
happening maybe your child's going
through something and there's a pattern
happening and this child's very reactive
or crying a lot and you find yourself
reacting to their reactivity and then
you feel guilty because you say things
and then you try and suppress it so
you're worried so there's this thing
going on where the child sees the mom or
dad or both being very anxious and but
not saying anything but so they don't
understand the parents reaction and they
can see because they can read through
they can read body language better than
a than a than a an adult so us not being
authentic with what we experiencing
pretending oh everything's fine when
it's not fine is terrible for a child
cuz they think that there's something
they've done cuz they can see you not
fine so bottom line be authentic about
how you are feeling obviously age
appropriate level so if you're having a
bad day and you come in and you and you
really worried about what the teacher
phoned you about while you were driving
home and the patterns of behavior that
you're seeing in your child plus the
pressure of work and pressure of life
and finances or whatever and you walk in
the door and you're actually very
irritable reactive um defensive as a as
a parent and you just don't do that
first connection with your kids as you
come back very well and there's a maybe
an argument and you say things you wish
you didn't say or you just whatever you
just this and you feel guilty and you
got to be let's say that that's
happening you need to First work on
yourself and the first thing is to say
okay I've had I and you walking through
and you yell at your kids the first
thing is to say to your kids okay I'm
sorry I am feeling emotion signal you
describe your signals you go through as
a process and I'll explain what that is
after I've explained the process I'm
going to demonstrate it first you say to
your kids I'm so sorry I so frustrated
today I'm so worried and I'm so
frustrated I'm so frustrated because I
just can't seem to fix this issue that's
going on um with with you I'm trying to
help you but I don't know how to do it
and I'm really worried about you and I'm
also very tired because work's been very
demanding the last few days so I'm
that's so i' say how I'm feeling then I
say it made me I F kind of in that
sentence let's analyze I I talked about
emotions I talked about the fact that
I'm that I'm Snappy whatever cuz I
snapped at the kids or whatever I'm
giving this example
behaviors um my body was very tense so
when I spoke to you I did this and I and
I was scary and my face was scary that's
my body reacting to how I'm feeling and
you know what I said and I'm my my
Outlook my perspective how I'm seeing
this situation how I'm looking at life
today is that I'm really feel don't know
what to do now You' you've identified
and you've outlined for the child or
children and for yourself you've done
the most phenomenal things you've
authentically helped the child
understand that adults also battle
you've been honest and authentic you've
made them feel better because they they
think oh it's not me it's Mom so you've
activated empathy or it's Dad or
whatever they're going through something
it's okay they you know they it's okay
to be messy so you've given them
permission to to be messy because life
is messy they don't have to suppress
their feelings I love it and I want to
point out something you said that's
really I think Super critical that that
parent that you described that exhausted
mom coming in the door didn't
immediately say you kids y'all are doing
this and you're doing this and you're
doing this the language you used was
very specific which is I'm feeling this
and I'm feeling that and one of the
things I think we do is we often cast
the emotional regulation of the adults
in the house onto our kids it's your job
to make sure I'm not mad it's your job
to make sure I'm not upset and kids
can't carry that weight and so there's
something powerful about saying I'm
worrying because I can't solve this
problem not that you're making me
worried or that you're making me mad or
you're hurting my feelings you're a kid
you don't have that kind of power I'm
not going to give you that kind of power
in my life but I'm struggling because I
can't solve this and I think that's such
a powerful switch for parents to flip if
they will take ownership of how they
feel and how they experience their own
homes